we called this the centroid  the people with paralysis this is a  return to life  Graham felstad an incredible human being  suffering with ALS became the first  person in the world to receive and use  one of these brain computer interfaces  once it's in place it's connected to  this tiny antenna that sits under the  skin in the chest  this collects the raw brain data and  sends it out of the body wirelessly to  then connect with external devices it's  kind of like learning how to ride a bike  it takes a bit of practice but once  you're rolling it becomes natural  now I just look on the screen where I  want to click and I'm texting messaging  the world via Twitter Graham  he said as his ALS was progressing that  it gave him immense Comfort to know that  even if his body was failing he was  always going to be able to tell his wife  that he loved her